er liebe zuschauer von den chor oder
maßnahmen profitieren unter anderem auch
die friseure
wir schalten jetzt für unser bild
reporter michael engelbert nach
hattingen in nordrhein westfalen
er ist dort im gespräch mit der
friseurin reise seelig die sich auf die
wiedereröffnung vorbereitet michael an
was muss freiwillig denn jetzt alles
denken ja guten morgen normen hieraus
hatting also wir stehen hier in dem
salon von friseurmeisterin eiselt schick
und frostig wie sind sie vorbereitet was
ist das für ein gefühl dass sie jetzt
tatsächlich nach fünf wochen im mai
wieder öffnen dürfen
ich muss sagen es ist ein sehr
gemischtes gefühl
wir freuen uns natürlich auch wieder auf
unsere ganzen kunden die wir dann auch
wieder gesund wieder sehen
wir müssen halt vorbereitungen treffen
hygienemaßnahmen einhalten die wir
gewissenhaft natürlich auch durchführen
werden
wie gesagt abstand halten trotz allem zu
unseren kunden geht leider nicht aber
hygiene maßnahmen wie zum beispiel
machten für mitarbeiter für kunden ein
weg umhänge desinfektion da wir halt
noch nicht wissen wieviele kunden wir
bedienen dürfen abstand halten zwischen
kunden ist halt sehr wichtig jetzt ist
sind wir hier heute morgen reingekommen
und hier ist schon wirklich sehr sehr
viel gemacht worden und zwar hat frau
sehr schick gestern schon mal den ganzen
laden desinfiziert an der kasse stehen
spuk wände und es werden aber auch noch
ganz spezielle masken für sie und ihre
mitarbeiter angefertigt und was sind das
für masken und was soll damit verhindert
werden das sind also plexiglas spuk
visier
die sollen besonders die
hygienevorschriften gut sein für uns wir
sind dann wirklich gesichert
natürlich müssen wir dann trotz allem
noch masken drunter tragen um uns noch
besser zu von der infektion zu schützen
also was wir auch sagen können wir sind
jetzt knapp anderthalb stunden hier im
laden und seit kurz vor acht wimmelt das
telefon quasi in einer tour aber frau
zach ist da auch noch so ein bisschen
skeptisch will jetzt noch keine termine
annehmen und da fragen sie doch mal was
macht sie so skeptischen nicht macht der
rückfall einfach ein bisschen skeptisch
falls doch wieder ein rückfall ist und
wie eine zweite welle bekommen was dann
mit den kunden dass wir müssen einfach
noch ein bisschen geduld haben und
wirklich nach und nach unsere kunden
termine rausgeben also und ganz ehrlich
wenn man wenn man so auf meinen kopf
guckt ich war jetzt auch schon fast vier
monate nicht mehr beim friseur da fragen
wir nochmal einmal die expertin halte
ich denn jetzt noch bis bis anfang mai
durch oder muss ich selbst die schere
ansetzen ich denke das gibt jetzt gerade
so wichtigeres als haare
sie halten es auf jeden fall aus und wir
freuen uns natürlich wenn wir sie am
fünften mal hier wieder antreten dürfen
so das sind doch versöhnliche worte hier
also frau zach ist auf jeden fall
gewählt und das team ist total motiviert
die kunden wieder quasi ja zu betreuen
und die haare zu schneiden und damit
gehen wir zurück aus dem schönen
heutigen nach berlin
vielen dank und liebe grüße